an alarming number of children are taken
to the hospital for accidental
poisonings by medicines
about 57,000 children under the age of
six visit the emergency room every year
for accidental consumption of
prescription pills over-the-counter
medicine or even vitamins in half of the
reported incidents children climbed a
chair a toy or other object to reach the
medicine these kids are crafty most
parents say that to turn away for only a
minute
and a Warner shows us how trouble can
happen oh so quickly don't we know it
sure can Gayle if you think that your
kids can't get to or get into the
medications in your home
one Indianapolis family says think again
it took just moments for Saira
MacLaren's two-year-old son Isaac to get
into a bottle of medication in a
bathroom high on a shelf medicine bottle
that has a childproof just a couple
moments his parents rushed him to an
Indianapolis hospital where he started
throwing up and having seizures
it was just very scary thinking he might
fall asleep and never wake up I kept
blaming myself saying oh you know it's
my fault that he was able to get to my
medicine it turns out those incidents
happen frequently a new report from Safe
Kids worldwide finds every nine minutes
a child under the age of six goes to the
emergency room because they accidentally
ingested medicine every hour a child is
hospitalized and every 12 days a child
dies researcher Morag Makai offered the
report parents don't really understand
what child resistant means we had about
half of parents who thought child
resistant meant childproof but what we
know about child resistant packaging is
it's not childproof it's actually
intended to slow the child down we're
gonna do a little experiment so just how
long does it take for a toddler to get
into a so-called child resistant bottle
of medication everybody take a bottle
Mackay's organization set up
this focus group for us at a Maryland
day care center with 11 children ranging
in age from 3 to 5
it took the children just seconds he
already opened yours some of those kids
literally got into the bottles in 2nd
yes I knew they would she may not have
been surprised but the mother of one of
those children Shanti Stephens sure was
didn't know that kids can easily open
these pill bottles and access the
medicine like it it's nothing no I know
I open
changes to packaging for medications
have made a difference some liquid
medications include flow regulators that
limit the amount a child will be able to
ingest if they do open a bottle but
Sarah MacLaren's family now keeps its
medication in a lockbox and she advises
other parents to do the same it can
happen to anyone we thought we did all
the right things we thought we had it
preventing from him getting into it but
he was determined and he got to it so I
would tell other parents they really
need to lock it up and make sure that
there is no way for them to get to it
easily well Isaac has made a full
recovery and we should point out that
the kids in the test were later
instructed they used it as a learning
lesson for those kids you know what do
we do don't touch that kind of thing but
the CDC says it found that packs like
these which are called blister packs cut
the accidental ingestion rate for some
medicines by 65 percent because it's a
lot harder to get into this than it is
in a bottle we talked about these also
these are what they call flow
restrictors law regulators they're
little devices that go in the top and
essentially if the kid does you know
open this it makes a lot harder so one
thing they mentioned to us also is to
watch the dosing for parents a lot of
parents will use a teaspoon out of the
kitchen that is not a correct dose you
need to use like little cups and think
milliliters not kitchen spoons yeah so
probably important Thank You Anna about